الامير ويليام امسك اخيه هاري من قميصه
واسقطه ارضا هذا بعض ما كشفه الامير
الاصغر في مذكراته اذا الاجواء ليست صافيه
لكن هاري سيحضر حفله تتويج والده الملك
تشارلز فاين سيجلس وسط هذا التوتر
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان هناك تخوف كبير من المشاكل التي
يمكن ان تحصل بين الاميرين في حفل التتويج
فقد كشفت مجله اوكي الامريكيه ان الامير
هاري سيجلس بعيدا عن شقيقه تجنبا لاندلاع
حساسيات بينهما
[موسيقى]
واوضحت المجله بان المنظمين حرصوا على ان
يجلس هاري وراء الامير ويليام بصفوف عده
مؤكده انهما لن يضطر الى مجامله بعضهما او
الانزعاج من حضورهما في حفل التتويج
[موسيقى]
ايضا احد المطالعين على شؤون العائله
المالكه في بريطانيا قال ان الامير هاري
سيجلس على بعد عشره صفوف من كبار افراد
العائله الاخرين عند تتويج والده وقال
كبير الخدم السابق بول بوريل ان هاري قد
يكون لديه القليل من الوقت للتحدث اصلا
الى الملك او شقيقه خلال زيارته الشهر
المقبل بل يعتقد هذا المسؤول السابق ان
هذه قد يدخل ويخرج من المملكه المتحده في
غضون 24 ساعه وكل ذلك بمفرده اي بدون
زوجته ميجا ماركل
[موسيقى]